como vemos entonces la participación de
las mujeres en la política ecuatoriana
en este momento
el otro que creo que es preocupante que
de tantos demonios candidatos sería una
propuesta de una candidatura
presidencial denomina lo que vivencia
que esta paridad de exigencia de paridad
y es de igualdad en cuanto al ejercicio
de los derechos políticos que está
consagrado en nuestra constitución
todavía no pasa de ser simplemente
letras de un texto fundamental y a esto
creo yo que tenemos que dirigir la
atención a qué es lo que están haciendo
las diligencias de los partidos para
efectivamente promover la participación
política de las mujeres lo cual es
sumamente importante porque en realidad
una mujer es una posición de poder si
pierde la posibilidad de trasladar el
nuevo eventual gobierno es persistente
de las preocupaciones que tenemos las
mujeres que dan a su nueva mayoría de la
población hacia políticas y leyes
encaminadas a garantizar adecuadamente
nuestros derechos
no solamente exista una candidatura de
una presidenta en una cantina candidata
mujer al presidente sino que también
preocupante lo que ha venido pasando en
las candidaturas de la asamblea donde se
ha visto que si bien hay varias mujeres
que están participando usualmente estas
mujeres no están como principales dichos
listas sino que están de segundas de
alterna de un candidato hombre principal
entonces eso nos lleva a pensar en
realidad que los partidos muchas veces
incluyen candidaturas mujeres
posiblemente para algunas otras o para
un poco más y la existencia de esta
disparidad de género pero en realidad no
existe un compromiso real desde los
diferentes partidos políticos de darle a
la mujer a las mujeres desde nuestros
diversos lugares perteneciendo también a
diferentes grupos una voz y una
posibilidad real de llegar a un cargo
público donde existían
pero una diferencia